Tower coming down will be one more of a
me
can you get out of this
Sara I'm sending you the coordinates of
one of the airfields it should take you
away from the IFC for zoo team if you
can ice pick an IMC access console we'll
still have a chance to take out the last
tower
doing great take out the remaining IMC
forces
I've made it to the airfield what do you
need locate a fighter launch console I
can configure the system for remote
activation with the ice pack
okay consult get it on the bed back up
out of here good luck
make it happen fish go comes down to how
much time we have left but yeah I think
I got this back
great your site's been destroyed look
we're working on a replace but I'll get
it to you when it's done
back it's working I got remote control
the IMC ships I'm gonna use them to cut
down the tower
pilots all towers are down I repeat all
towers are down watch out for the
incoming wildlife they won't play
favorites between you and the IMC great
work people
bullheaded ammeter within the hour it's
time for the main event Macallan out
fish back to the IFV briefly great know
what coming all out of salt doesn't have
to put out like this
a lots changed in the last fifteen years
since you wore this uniform Mac I won't
let you walk away this time
have you really made a difference in the
IFC market